o o ciclo de aprendizado do aluno que
esse é um slide mais importante o aluno
pessoal não aprende nada em sala de aula
o aluno realmente não aprende nada sala
de aula o que o aluno faz
ele entende a matéria em sala de aula é
o primeiro ciclo a primeira fase do
aprendizado
o aluno entende a maré a matéria em sala
de aula e quando ele estuda em casa
sozinho é que ele aprende o que ele
entendeu em sala de aula e quando ele
dorme à noite ele fixa somente o que ele
aprendeu então é isso que vou fazer é a
palestra mais ou menos sobre isso
fazendo analogia o computador quem bolou
o computador
ele verificou exatamente nosso cérebro o
nosso cérebro possui uma memória de
curto prazo assim como o computador
essa memória ram todo mundo sabe
computando memória ram
quando nós desligamos computador tudo o
que está nessa memória ram é apagada e
nós temos a memória grande é o hd é o hd
é uma memória de longo prazo pessoal
nosso cérebro é exatamente igual tá
nós temos ali uma memória ram memória de
curto prazo ali que estão vendo aí eu
chamei de ram e tem um hd está em
vermelho ali é a memória de longo prazo
então nosso objetivo da palestra o que
fazer com a melhor forma para levar
informação da memória de pique de
pequeno a pequena provisório a memória
de curto prazo para a memória de longo
prazo esse é o nosso objetivo está então
aquilo que eu falei pra vocês na sala de
aula ninguém entende nada e aprendizagem
pessoal são três fases a primeira fase o
aluno entende a matéria em sala de aula
é aquele momento não só em sala de aula
o aluno pode entender também no ambiente
virtual e tá entendendo
uma determinada matéria só que todas as
informações do que vem durante o dia
pessoal seja por e mail à revista seja
pelas redes sociais
tudo isso vai pra nossa memória de curto
prazo
vai pra nossa memória de curto prazo ali
todas as informações vão pra ele aí tem
a segunda fase que realmente ela não
está aprendendo
olha que acha que falava no início do
século passado pessoal sem ter esse
estudo todos sobre o cérebro
eu nunca ensino os alunos apenas tento
criar condições para que ele possa
aprender sozinho então aí
durante o estudo aquele momento que o
aluno está ajudando sozinho que ele
realmente está aprendendo
ali as portas dessa memória de curto
prazo começam a se abrir
então todas aquelas informações ali ó
quando o aluno dorme quando quem está
ajudando dorme batuca lata do lixo é
exatamente igual àquele computador
aquela memória principal que quando
desliga na palavra do lixo aqui
as informações são deletadas poucas
informações virão realmente conhecimento
então nosso objetivo como fazer para
gerar conhecimento
então o pessoal ninguém consegue ninguém
consegue trocar o pneu com o carro
andando na realidade mesma coisa
acontece você não conta não consegue
copiar as informações da memória de
curto prazo para a memória de longo
prazo contra acordado então por isso que
o sono é muito importante no aprendizado
do aluno está o sono é a terceira fase
do aprendizado que é o fix a é o fix
aquela matéria então que foi apreendida
com alunos do sozinho então durante o
sono é que realmente o aluno vai fixar
aquela matéria e durante o sono profundo
pessoal
nós temos um determinado sono profundo
que algumas informações que o aluno não
aprendeu vai para o lixo mas tudo que o
aluno aprendeu sozinho estudou sozinho
ele vai ele vai virar conhecimento e vai
pra sua memória de longo prazo está na
memória a longo prazo pessoal significa
que há dez 15 anos
o aluno vai lembrar daquela matéria foi
estudado e não somente estudou de
colocar aquela prova a prova no outro
dia né a prova no outro dia eles devem
tirar 10 e não uma semana depois ele
esquece aquela matéria não aprender a
aprender pra sempre
e não para tirar uma boa nota e como é
que funciona é o aprendizado em si psol
na realidade nós temos uma rede neural
com bilhões de neurônios trilhões de
sinapses onde estão as informações e
durante o sono existe ó e se algo está
azul aqui ele está dormindo ali eo a
existe uma nova reconfiguração dessa
rede neural então se teve um aprendizado
ser seu aluno aprendeu aquele dia por
exemplo é a equação de segundo grau como
determinar quando o segundo grau ele tem
um caminho neural aqui que foi criado
que foi criado durante o sono durante o
sono telha essa reconfiguração da rede
neurais
então durante o sono todo o aprendizado
tudo que ele realmente ele aprendeu uma
nova reconfiguração das redes neurais
vão ser vai ser criada tá então o
pessoal por isso que eu falo aula
assistida hoje é aula estudada hoje
antes se passa a noite de sono que
quando o aluno dorme se ele só entendeu
aquela matéria que o professor passou
vai 80 por cento vai ser perdida e daqui
a um mês vai ser difícil você até pode
estudar mas vai demorar três vezes mais
o tempo para lembrar o que o professor
passou naquele momento tá então o
pessoal infelizmente o aluno no brasil
99% dos alunos
eles estudam quando o pessoal no momento
da prova 1% aquele aluno mais
inteligente eles estudam no momento da
aula o professor deu a matéria o aluno
tem que estudar naquele mesmo dia a
matéria tá
infelizmente e olha essa e olha essa
pesquisa que da universidade de harvard
verificou o seguinte quando o aluno
escuta ele só consegue assimilar 10% que
está escutando
quando o aluno ver entende na sala de
aula por exemplo ele consegue assimilar
80 por 20%
mas quando ele faz quando ele aprende
quando ele estuda sozinho aí ele
consegue assimilar 80% do que ele está
realmente
estudando aprendendo e quando e o mais
inteligente é aquele que aprende para
poder ensinar e se assimila 90% é aquele
aluno que tem que estudar porque amanhã
ele vai ter que dar uma aula de
monitoria que amanhã ele vai explicar
por um amigo então essa é a melhor forma
de estudar é é aprender sabendo que vai
ter que ensinar aquela matéria então é
são os três pilares do aprendizado
o sono como já falei a alimentação
saudável é algo muito importante é um
dos pilares para a energia do cérebro a
concentração e atividade física também
diariamente fazer uma atividade física
de pelo menos 40 minutos uma hora todos
os dias e são os três pilares do
aprendizado pra deixar o nosso cérebro
tem bastante energia com a concentração
tudo melhorar bastante e não esquecer
também a água pessoal é beber água é
algo muito importante pelo menos dois
litros de água todo dia é algo muito
importante para o nosso raciocínio
lógico nosso cérebro pro nosso pra nossa
concentração a água é muito importante e
agora como na realidade o aluno quer
estudar
eu estou nem falando em sala de aula mas
o aluno tem dificuldade mas não
verifiquei isso inclusive fazendo
algumas pesquisas que o aluno quando
está no 5º 6º ano 7º ano
às vezes ele quer estudar só quem não
sabe nem como estudar e não sabe como
estudar então é muito importante
primeiro de tudo administrar o tempo
fazer um planejamento do estudo esse
planejamento é uma planilha mesmo a
segunda feira eu vou estudar mecânica de
duas das três floresta amazônia de 4 e 5
esta palestra do pessoal do enem também
é bem interessante porque eles começam a
fazer esse planejamento semanal é um
planejamento semanal e isso dá força
para o aluno esse planejamento se ele
sabe que se ele se ele conseguir
conseguir executar todo o que está
planejado ele praticamente ele consegue
colocar aquela matéria em dia então
colocar isso no papel
no domingo à noite é muito importante
que estudar
segunda a outro domingo tá isso aqui
pessoal é um gráfico bem interessante é
o seguinte olha só quem é quem quem
fizesse algoritmo aqui tá de estudo
nunca mais esquece determinada matéria
nunca mais
daqui a 10 15 20 anos ele vai lembrar o
que ele estudou
hoje tá olha só no primeiro dia o aluno
lá aprendeu a matéria então tem 100%
desculpa que tem 100% de conhecimento e
entendimento daquela matéria ora esse
gráfico aqui se ele nunca mais ver ele
ficar aquela matéria
no segundo dia mais de 50 por cento
lembra de nada 70 por cento da matéria
não lembro uma semana depois é só lembra
20 por cento naquele assunto no final de
30 dias
ele só lembra de 10 por cento daquele
assunto se ele nunca mais foi a revisão
naquela matéria
mas se ele no primeiro dia o professor
deu aquela matéria ele ele chegar em
casa e estudar aquela matéria ele vai
demorar uma aula de 50 minutos
ele vai demorar na faixa de 20 a 30
minutos para ajudar aquela matéria do
primeiro dia
pelo segundo dia ele tirar dez minutos
para realizar aquela matéria novamente e
vai precisar de 10 minutos
uma semana depois ele pega aquela
matéria ele já vai precisar de cinco
minutos para realizar aquela matéria
um mês depois ele vai precisar de dois a
quatro minutos para realizar aquela
mesma matéria então o pessoal o gráfico
de aprendizado dele vai ficar na faixa
de 90 por cento de conhecimento daquela
determinada matéria
então esse aqui é o melhor goleiro tiago
que existe pra pessoa aprender mas
aprender para sempre
há sempre aquela determinada matéria
isto é fazer pelo menos a revisão do
primeiro dia a revisão do segundo dia
uma semana depois de um mês depois a
matéria então é algo bem importante
mas como estudar essa matéria como
estudar essa matéria diagramas também
olha só a revolução francesa que isso
aqui é o chamado mapa mental ele fez um
resumo de 80 páginas do livro uma
determinada página então aqui
e tem o mapa mental que chama de mapa
mental todo um resumo de 80 páginas de
um livro
e aí ele vai ficar estudando que ele vai
ficar lendo o livro toda vez não ele vai
ficar ajudando o seu resumo tem os
resumos aqueles resumos que todo mundo
faz
ele lê a primeira vez determinada
matéria e depois foi determinado em
resumo ele vai ter que ficar e estudando
aquele determinado resumo então o
pessoal
na realidade o mais importante aqui essa
palestra que dura na faixa de 2 horas
está a gente fala sobre o cérebro de
hemisfério direito espera esquerdo
o tipo de de inteligência que existe
existem então na realidade o mais
importante o tópico da palestra é a
gente falar sobre o ciclo de aprendizado
do aluno esse tipo de aprendizado o
aluno em sala de aula ele entende a
matéria
ele aprende quando ele estava sozinho
que é o mais importante de tudo é o
aluno se transformar no alto de data
para lembrar uma coisa você não vai
estudar na frente do computador não é
que quando se está estudando na frente
do computador você o seu cérebro está é
fazer resumos a gente vai resumo na
frente do computador
não existe fazer resumos na frente do
computador que quando seu certa teclando
ele não está armazenando que está sendo
o conteúdo da alíquota fazer um resumo
na frente do computador
quem estudar desde o computador de lado
e papel e caneta fazendo um resumo a eu
quero entender uma matéria que está no
comando beleza é o computador
leio lá e entendo mas na hora de estudar
na hora de aprender é papel caneta e
resumo eu posso fazer pesquisa
eu posso entender uma matéria pelo
computador
então a definição de entender e aprender
pessoal não é algo completamente
diferente nós temos a memória de curto
prazo que você entende
vai dar aquela memória de curto prazo e
o que você aprende abre as portas pra
quando você for dormir quando dormir
fixa' aquela aquela o que você realmente
aprendeu e não que você entendeu o
pessoal então
muito obrigado pela participação de
vocês e espero que os tipos de
aprendizado de vocês que sirva pra vocês
mude a forma de cada um estudo muito
obrigado sol
[Aplausos]
[Música]